hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from round 11 of
the 2021 tata still chess tournament uh
it's alireza ferruccia versus fabiano
caruana now both of them still have very
good chances of winning the tournament
uh i decided not to show that the carlos
and geary game even though
giri is currently leading the tournament
because it was too too big of a snooze
fest uh if you guys are interested check
it out somewhere but it was uh
i don't know there was really nothing to
uh to actually show there it was just
some sort of a deep
analysis by both of them and i i didn't
feel like like showing it to you so
sorry about that if you were looking
forward to that game and also it was an
italian game and
they did not go for the evans gambit so
uh that being said
let's check out this very nice game as i
think this one is the most action-packed
game that
uh did happen today so alireza with the
white pieces
opens with e4 uh we have e5 by fabi
knight to f3
knight to c6 and bishop to c4 uh we have
bishop the c5 and now of course uh do
you think the evans gambit was played in
this game
uh no it wasn't uh in this game c3 was
played we have the joko piano
so the main line and now knight to f6 uh
we have d3
d6 and now just castles we have h6 so
this is all very standard stuff that we
always
uh always explain rook to e1 and now
castles often we mentioned the knight g4
doesn't really do anything
because you can just play rook to e2 and
this is perfectly fine for white if
someone does this against you
so castles uh knight beat to d2 and now
bishop back to b6 uh you don't want this
bishop stuck here
when d4 comes and then it will come
with an attack on the bishop as well uh
and here there are a couple of moves
that exist in this position but a for
the move alireza plays
is a new move so already as of move nine
we have a completely new game
and let's see how fabi deals with this
he doesn't want to
meet some ideas like a5 so he pushes a5
himself
and now bishop to b5 by alireza putting
more pressure on the center by
challenging this knight
and here uh fabi actually goes for
knight to g4 he puts pressure on this f2
pawn
but like we said whenever this happens
in the italian most of the times
rook to e2 just takes care of all of the
threats so now the f2 pawn is defended
and for those of you who are maybe new
to the channel and new to chess
you might think it's a good idea to
capture the pawn here because you kind
of win the rook
uh but you do not want to give up two
pieces for
uh for the for the rook that's not uh
that that's not worth it
if there are such a gentleman watching
this
this video so here we have knight to e7
uh getting the knight away preparing to
push c6d five striking the center and so
on
uh here we have d4 now it is possible so
now alireza goes for it and now
knight is shifted over to g6 we have
knight to f1
and now d5 by fabi so fabi now took care
of all of his uh
weaknesses in the center and now uh
there's a lot of tension here
everything can be captured and alireza
needs to find a good move here he
decides for e captures on d5
fabi goes e captures on d4 and now
before recapturing first
alireza kicks away this very strong
knight from from g4 we have knight back
to f6
and only now knight captures on d4
knight captures on d5
and now the rule goes back to e1 so the
queen can enter the game also
uh the rook was looking kind of weird
there on e2
so here knight d to f4 by favi and now
with the bishop's diagonal
blocked uh queen to g5 could be could be
a very tricky idea
so here bishop to e3 you do not want to
watch out for this bishop all this time
and now c6 pushes
alireza's bishop back and now uh you
have to go
bishop captures on f4 or bishop to e2
because bishop to c4
is a very uh well it's a very bad move
but it's
uh it's incredibly difficult to spot
that it's a bad move but uh you know
feel free to pause the video and try to
take advantage of this bishop to c4 move
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
taking advantage of the bishop's weird
position and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's
knight capture sun g2 that's the stuff
and now of course you have to capture
the knight otherwise
wha what are you even doing so king
captures on g2
and now queen to h4 and now you are
going after this h3 pawn and of course
uh if the knight goes back uh to help
out with the defense then you can just
pick up the bishop
and you haven't sacrificed anything and
you are enjoying a much better position
you've shattered the white king's
defenses
and your position is great and if king
g1 still just c5 you kick away the
knight and then you pick up the bishop
so it works every er
you know either way so after bishop to
c4 fabi misses this
very sneaky idea and he goes for bishop
to c7 instead he wants to put some
pressure along the dark squares maybe
even go queen to d6 maybe
deliver some ideas but for the moment
the knight on f1 is nicely guarding the
h2 square
so alareza doesn't have to worry about
any checkmating patterns uh
for for the most so here knights the g3
and again fabi doesn't go for knight to
g tonight to g2 is even possible here
captures captures and queen h4
uh giving a very very promising position
to black
uh but uh fabi fabi doesn't enjoy this
so sort of a case of uh
something that's called the double
blindness when neither of the player
spots it so knight back to d5 and now
bishop back to d2 not allowing this
trade we have queen to d6
now putting pressure alongside this
diagonal if this knight moves then it
could be very tricky
and the bishop back to b3 uh we have
bishop to b7 developing the bishop
connecting rooks and now
knight to f3 again the knight returns
the h2 square is covered
so now this knight can move with rook f
to e8 and now
queen to c2 and here you have to be a
little bit careful
you have to be always careful when you
have such tension in the position for
example if you're not careful play
something like knight f6
uh queen captures and g6 just wins the
game you cannot recapture
uh as the bishop is spinning that uh
that f pawn
so instead after queen to c2 we have
knight g to f4
and now again what do you play here here
alireza goes to rook
8 to d1 just brings another rook into
the game
fabi trades a pair of rooks captures
captures and goes
queen to f6 so fabi mounting a very nice
attack here the bishop pair is almost
fully operational
uh we have knights the d4 backed by
already and now
rook to d8 uh we have rook to e4
now uh setting up a a defensive
perimeter along that
fourth rank uh and uh fabi goes queen to
g6
now there was always this c5 on the uh
in the position to kick away this knight
but fabi uh not interested not
interested and he just continues with
his plan queen to g6
now the rook doesn't have all that many
squares as fabio would be able to trade
queens very easily
uh so instead we have bishop captures on
b5 we have knight captures on d5
and now comes knight g to e knight g to
f5 so
putting a lot of pressure here uh
towards the black king but now
again uh we have queen to f6 you have to
be careful here because
if you play something like rook to e8
then for example rook capture 78 bishop
captures and c4
will be deadly you lose the knight if
the knight moves just 97 check picks up
the queen
as the the the fork is coming so after
knight to g to f5 we have queen to f6
fabi gets the queen out of that um nasty
square
to avoid any knight checks and now rook
the g4
so again putting a lot of pressure here
uh towards fabi's king
there are now ideas of knight captures
on a6 you're not going to be able to
capture that with anything because the
bishop
also attacks the h6 pawn and here fabi
needs to be very careful and
indeed with a move like king to h8 uh it
seems like fabi uh
gains a winning position uh out of uh
out of this position because now you
really don't have a good continuation to
the position for example
rook h4 you prepare to sacrifice a piece
here it's not a problem bishop captures
knight captures
uh and now knight the e7 going after the
trade and there's just not
much you can do this is threatened this
is defending this also this
is being pressured so not much for you
to do here if you go for some sort of a
sacrifice knight captures here
then you capture the rook knight
captures on f7 with
check king g8 knight captures and after
bishop captures
uh you simply do not have compensation
for the sacrificed piece and black would
be black would be winning this
so favi does not find king to h8 instead
fabi plays g6
and he now allows uh well rather
a lot to to alireza who immediately goes
for knight captures on h6 with
check we have king to f8 and now rook to
e4
again cutting off the king from the e
file and freeing up the g4 square for
the knight
which is very important so here uh you
could go for something like
g5 uh it is possible then after an ig4
you cleared the g6 square for your queen
and again
you make it problematic for for the rook
to move however
fabi goes for knight to f4 instead and
now we have uh knight to g4 attacking
fabi's queen
bishop captures on g for h captures and
now
king to g7 and now it's a quite a
difficult position to hold here
and uh of course uh alireza needs to
find a very good
very good plan on how to approach this
position and he starts by
uh eliminating the knight on f4 bishop
captures on f4
bishop captures and now the very tricky
knight to f5 with
check there were of course a lot of
different ways you could play this
position
but all it is are very confident in this
one he played it rather quickly
knight to f5 with check now you have to
capture it otherwise you just lose a
piece
so captures we have rook captures now
the f1 is pinned
queen g5 attacks the rook and now rook
captures on f5
we have queen captures on g4 and now
rook to f3 and here
we have a very very interesting position
uh where the players
have reached time control or rather uh
white only reached uncontrolled and they
were extremely low on time
like under a minute both of them and now
of course rook g3 will just
win the game for whites while it is a
played queen to a fab you played queen
to h5
and now both players officially reached
move 40 reach time control and now
alireza is up upon
uh fabi's king is a little bit uh naked
over there
and uh can alireza win this or can or
or does he have to settle for a draw
here so here
alireza played c4 he wanted to free up
this diagonal for his queen to attack
the black king
but there was the also there was there
was also the immediate
just rook to g3 check king to f8 and now
rook to d3 uh forcing a rook trait here
and after captures captures now you can
play a queen end game
uh being up upon but if you've ever
studied queen end games you
you know that that's every player's
nightmare it doesn't matter how strong
you are
uh more often than not you want to you
want to avoid a queen end game doesn't
matter if you're up a pawn because those
are just
incredibly difficult uh but here after
queen to h5
uh alireza decided against the queen
against the queen end game he decided to
go for c4
and now fabi tries to set up a defense
we have rook to d4
we have queen to c3 now pinning the rook
here preparing to capture it and now you
could play
uh c5 here but see if you go for c5 then
we'll see something like rook to h3
queen to e5 and then
yeah you have to be very careful
otherwise rook to d1 will be deadly
probably queen to c1 and then the game
continues maybe with some queen to h6
action and so on
but instead after queen to c3 we have
queen to e5 immediately by fabi
and now rook to d3 again here we have to
decide do you trade
or do you go for g3 g3 is very tricky
because now rook to d1 check allows a
queen trade king g2 queen captures on c3
rook captures on c3 and now rook to b1
is
is a very uh tricky idea after rook to
b3 defending rook
a1 and black will pick off one of the
pawns for example captures captures and
now after b3
you have uh two against two on the queen
set and two against one on the king side
uh black has uh excellent drawing
chances
so instead after queen to e5 we have the
immediate rook to d3 by alireza
and now c5 by fabi just defending that
that rook there was also rook the e4 if
you want to
go for a queen trade like this captures
captures but then after b3 white's
position
is is a bit better than the than in the
previous
rook and game that we've shown uh black
doesn't have a clear way of
getting going after white spawns uh but
okay uh as
a c5 was played instead just defending
that rook
now we have rook to g3 with czech king
f8
and now queen captures on a5 by alireza
grabbing that pawn
and now if fabi doesn't have something
up his sleeve it's going to be
it's going to be a winning position for
alireza
but fabi finds rook to d1 check king to
h2
now comes queen to h5 check rook to h3
queen to e5 check g3 and now
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the only move that
doesn't lose for fabi uh while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
being an absolute master of sporting a
move that doesn't lose
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's queen to f5
you have to go after that pawn you you
don't want to go after it with queen to
e2 because then queen captures and c5
comes with
check so from f5 you defend against
everything and you attack the f2 pawn so
this is the
the good stuff so here alireza has to
play something he plays queen to a8 with
check and now you cannot go to g7 if g7
then is just a check made into
check king g6 queen eight queen to h6 is
checkmate
so after this you have to give up
another pawn this is what fabi found
king to e7 queen captures on b7 with
check
and now rook to d7 attacking the queen
and also going after the f2 pawn that
will come with
check and now everyone said all right
this is an instant draw if
queen to g2 then just rook d2 and that's
it uh you're threatening to win the game
with
rook f2 so kg1 has to defend and then
it's just a nice perpetual rook d1
checking h2
you go after the f1 king again blocks
check it goes
back it's a draw by perpetual repetition
uh so here after rook to d7 this is what
they thought alireza would play but
alireza played queen to h1
so he doesn't defend the f2 pawn at all
and here
fabi uh had to figure out how how to
continue this position because
okay you will obviously capture this
pawn but maybe
maybe even this but this would be a
terrible blunder because if you go
and try to win the game like this
queenie one check just wins the rook
here
on d2 so instead after queen to h1 okay
fabi goes after the pawn
queen captures an f2 and now queen to g2
so at least alireza can now
kind of force a rook end game but after
rook to d2 we have captures
captures with check and now king to g1
we have rook captures on b2
and now rook to h5 battle it is going
after that c5 pawn
uh if rook the h2 trying to avoid the
rook trade and put the rook behind the
pawn
black will just deliver a check first
check king g2 and then rook b4 and then
you are free to collect the pawns
so instead after rook captures on g2 we
have rooked the h5 by alireza
and now rook to a2 going after this pawn
we have captures on c5
captures on a4 and now king to g2
alireza starts bringing his king into
the game
he's up a pawn but it's uh it's it's a
well-known
rook in the game that is a draw unless
the side that is
a pawn down makes some sort of a mistake
so king the d6 we have rook d5
check king e6 and now rook to d4 defends
the pawn
and prepares to go to to f4 to keep an
eye on everything but after king f5
uh king e5 rook f4 uh we have f5 by fabi
and now
king to h3 and after rook to a3 it was
in this position
uh on move 61 that fabian alireza agreed
to a draw
as there is nothing more to be done here
by either side now if you try something
like king h4 go up the board
you can't really do that because this
pawn is hanging and you don't have any
other moves if you move the rook then
you allow the king into the position
so it's a it's a dead draw you'd have to
just repeat king h3 rook a3 king h4
uh and so on not nothing to be done here
uh so yeah after this rook they three
move they agreed to a draw and
uh they missed their opportunity to
catch up to anishigiri who is uh
still leading the tournament uh but
we're gonna show the standings after
i show a few more games that happened in
round 11.
but yeah really crazy stuff first fabi
had probably what seemed to be a winning
position
he missed that uh knight captures on g2
move twice
then alireza grabbed the upper hand and
there there were a lot of ways to
consider
the to continue but the time was ticking
and uh
the the path the path alireza chose uh
uh brought him to a crossroad where he
could either play a rook and game
being up a pawn which doesn't work or go
into a queen end game being up
upon but uh he he decided against that
and in the end
a draw uh so that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
maximilian maher gabriel sesimondi
uh solars michelle alexander delaire and
albert zaverasway atlas for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing uh with the coverage of the
tata steel checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day